[Applause]
[Music]
you're not shooting high so here at
Toronto big day
got some media in the morning here that
I'm about to do and then we've got the
hastened hustle conference which is a
bunch of events speech QA lunch and then
later the pop up but for the case whist
launch which were both rockin Tyler is
not rocking it he's rocking under
k-swiss
I'm impressed by that
I got a I got a run to the core I'm
going to pop up
you guys I have a I've some free passes
to the conference I'm speaking at
anybody else need a pass for the
conference thank you most important
things to keep in mind for someone who
wants to build a public-facing personal
brand in your mind
number one you better be a good person
you better recognize that if you have
skeletons you better own them or know
that they're going to be vulnerable
because that game is that ship has
sailed
this is something I started talking
about 2008 and crush it it obviously is
now very real because of all the stuff
that's happened with the me2 movement
which is phenomenal that's number one
number two you have to have empathy for
your audience if you're the kind of
person that gets upset that Johnny pants
ninety nine says you're ugly or you're
stupid you might as well close up shop
now I have empathy for people that think
I'm a snake oil salesmen are full of
crap or not good or who knows or I curse
too much like you have to have empathy
because that's what allows you to move
forward instead of being combative with
the audience which is your ultimate
asset number three you have the respect
context the same picture does not work
across Facebook Instagram Pinterest
snapchat and you have to have
understanding of the context of the
psychology of the person when they're on
that platform to make the content pop
and resonate so the religion of context
not just content is essential the single
biggest reason I maintain Gary Vee is to
be a doer right I mean to me my personal
brand is about top of the funnel
awareness but way more importantly I'm a
practitioner I post on Instagram like I
reply to the apps I have to listen you
have to know what you're doing what's
some advice you give to somebody that
just doesn't know what they want to do
right now just speak your truth right
speaker truth like including that you
have depression or that you don't know
what you're doing or that you're really
good at cutting hair or that you love
the Smurfs I think the truth is the
biggest win right and I think that for
me that is really played out in our
society today there's no more hiding the
Internet is all encompassing and
nobody's gonna be able to front like if
you're not motivated and optimistic
motivational content is not going to
work for you
you know if you aren't thoughtful and
smart about you know sports you're not
gonna win you can only win on two things
the thing that you understand the best
or the thing that you're most passionate
or authentic about those are the only
two winning formulas I think too many
people want to fake it too they make it
or project someone they're not
which is why 99% of people are losing
social media is being really big for a
while you're obviously a massive
influencer what do you think is next
when it comes to brands cutting through
in a very fragmented market when it is
digital voice all right
I'm obsessed there I've not seen
anything that reminds me of the iPhone
with social networks on top of it the
way I feel about Google Apple pawed and
Alexa with that we have not felt the
apps on top of the voice thing yet in a
lot of scenarios voice is a far more
effective efficient medium to deliver
information when I'm brushing my teeth
it's better for me to listen to my day
when I'm driving it's better for me to
listen or commute so to me I care about
communication I'm not as I'm not as I'm
not bright enough or as smart as my
partner in crime here to understand kind
of the frameworks the technologies the
inventions that are needed to what I'm
very good at is understanding consumer
behavior and what we're gonna do with
those things and so for me voice is
emerging because of AI and technology
advances by some of the biggest Internet
companies in the world and that's why
I'm very passionate about it the
Internet's the highway the big companies
are the toll booths you've got to pay
those toe boots but you have to be very
strategic and how you pay Facebook and
Instagram and Google are great for me
because I look at them as frenemies
there are places where I can get
awareness but I don't want to be at the
mercy of them which is why I'm prolific
across all platforms because I'm di
versifying
media companies should be in trouble if
they put all their eggs in the Facebook
bucket that is ludicrous strategy
where's your podcast
where's your original show where's your
vlog where's your email list where's
your CRM where's your text messaging
platform I wish people understood how
hard it is to have a business that
there's a million dollars I would also
add the part that I'm most concerned
about which is that it's awfully lonely
and I think most people you have to be
unbelievably strong emotionally to be
able to deal with loneliness and in a
world where I think we're talking more
about depression and mental health I
want to make that a bigger part of the
conversation because I think it leads to
a bad place
it is a very lonely sport because not
only are you lonely and you're
responsible for everything everybody's
watching and judging your parents your
best friends everybody that's lonely do
you many gonna actually I'm gonna flip
it up what about some Nipsey Hussle what
is that Nipsey and IPS to get there yep
like that
in the expression all right being
influential means that when you do
something meaning you say something you
wear something you write something you
act on something other people are
affected by that and want to be inspired
to then also do that as well or some
variation thereof so I think it's it's
somebody who has an impact on other
people at scale and and influences
creates an action from their own actions
as far as what's the difference between
an entrepreneur and a want rapport I
mean look you know entrepreneurs are
cool right now it has a moment this is
not something that we grew up with even
20 years ago and so what's happening is
like anything that's cool rappers
athletes or anything else there's a lot
of young people that aspire to be what
is cool entrepreneurship is cool which
leads to a lot of people that want to
become that you know I think there's a
lot of cynicism a lot of times on the
inner city of like oh you think the only
way out is being a rapper or an athlete
I think that's happening with white
America and the rest of the world right
now around entrepreneurship everybody
thinks that's their way out unlike a lot
of other things when you claim that
you're an entrepreneur everybody starts
watching from your parents to your
friends to the world and everybody will
watch you fail and you have to be very
emotionally strong to deal with that
loss that is very different than getting
bad grades in school that is very
different than getting you get fired
from a job you blame the boss your
business fails it's your fault and
there's no escaping it I'm very
concerned about the post-game of this
era of people getting into depression
and even Werth's which is why I'm
talking about self-awareness and truths
that make people uncomfortable it's not
fun for me to say that 98% of people out
there aren't going to succeed it doesn't
make me feel cool and them not cool it's
just something we need to talk about so
we're prepared for the ramifications of
the glorifying of the entrepreneurial
journey
[Music]
we're you nice to see ya
gets all the home there's a good bro
[ __ ] awesome onr your wrestling
fingers got everything minutes looking
macho man that way what's up that's
what's up homies macho man baby that's
really [ __ ] rad you gotta understand I
was really selling stuff at a very young
age I'm talking first grade [ __ ] like
even looking at this brings back
memories like by the bag at a discount
sell them for a quarter you know like
you know so I long before
entrepreneurship was cool you know long
before I had anybody to look up to it
was in me in the same way that like
people like sang or wrote poem like it
was deeply in me so very early on I was
like [ __ ] school like I'm not gonna win
at this game
you know I was super into the social
parts you know I had a lot of friends I
loved being popular I loved being
popular with the coolest kid in school
and the biggest nerd and you know she's
so [ __ ] confident she's the most
confident person on my whole team but
you know what I mean like I ran I enjoy
I took a lot of pride in being friendly
with everybody I remember that being a
big theme for me yeah that's exactly
it's my superpower I'm grateful for
having so many natural talents so for me
it's less about insecurity and I got to
prove it or stick it though I love that
and I love competition
like I like stick like I want to beat
everybody but not but more or more
what's driving me is [ __ ] I was gifted
with the best ingredients I better get
my chef's game up to make this dish
because I was given so I love it it's a
great analogy like I've got to get my
chef's game up like I've been given the
best foie gras the best beef from Japan
and Argentina the best vegetables and
and [ __ ] I better make the greatest meal
because if somebody makes a better meal
yeah than me with less because the
ingredients were given no I hear you
so for me it's about how do I keep
challenging myself to become the best
chef in the world because my DNA is off
the [ __ ] charts my origin is [ __ ]
all time if you don't have a gold
bracelet what the [ __ ] I am gonna hope
to put pressure on everybody in this
free to get really self-aware really
fast I think the reason I have a happy
life and things have gone well and more
importantly forget about me being a
focus group of one everybody that I know
that has happiness traces back to some
incredible incredible commitment to
self-awareness an incredible thing
happens in your life when you stop
bullshitting yourself it's incredible to
me that you can start a brand from zero
have a smart Instagram and Facebook
strategy sell it on Shopify plus and
Amazon and build a real business in a
year or two that is remarkable that is
incredible and that is what makes this
era special let me tell you this again
and I referenced it earlier my friends
humans will look back at this era they
will look back at this year like you are
living in one of those interesting times
that will be reviewed over and over and
over because you live during the era of
the internet being established a
blockchain being established this is big
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is big [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is printing press this is big this
is big big big big big and so now what
you have to do is be on the offense
practically I am so frustrated by
watching all the teenagers and 20 year
olds take full advantage of this
opportunity because they don't know any
better and for the 40 and 50 and 60 year
olds closing their mind without
realizing that they're gonna live for
the next 40 years
and this [ __ ] land grab is for you
too and good news old [ __ ] you have
experienced [ __ ] 42 I'm not [ __ ]
young not a baby I just understand how
good the opportunity is and I struggle
with my 46 and 59 and 60 70 year old
friends who think because that's how we
grew up that they're getting to the end
of the years without recognizing how
much healthier we are as a race in our
70s 80s and 90s you compound how fast
medicine is advancing there's a the
pharma I mean if you're if you're 40 to
60 in this room your numbers are gonna
look like a hundred 110 I'm like what do
people think is happening here and if
you're 63 in this room and you're living
another 50 years you're only at half
time but when we grew up
you were towards the end and I am
imploring everybody in this room from
the youngest of [ __ ] in this room to
the oldest of [ __ ] in this room I'm
imploring you I'm imploring you to
understand how incredible this is which
is the following
Ronald [ __ ] Reagan ran the free world
with a computer not as powerful as this
only five minutes ago shit's happening
and you need to take advantage of your
thing and the fact that most of you are
not taking advantage of this opportunity
because of the insecurities that your
[ __ ] up parents or your neighborhood
gave to you breaks my [ __ ] heart and
I am completely obsessed with putting
out content that scale to get people to
understand that not posting on things on
social media because Johnny pants 47
said you're ugly or stupid watching my
60 year old friends not do things
because they feel weird of the judgment
of their grandkids making fun of them
that they don't understand how to use
snapchat remind your 13 year old
granddaughter that she doesn't know jack
[ __ ] about life
sign my book I just want I can Jersey
from Toronto and so I really really need
people to understand what's actually
happening here if you are not
communicating to the world on these
platforms you're invisible fix it
thank you
[Applause]
actually the reason I thought that
school four years ago it's real quick
real quick are your parents here they
weren't happy at the time but they're
pretty happy now so go [ __ ] figure
anyways in last four years my brothers
and I we built a franchise now seven
locations actually in the city we sell
cold-pressed juices but it's been
happened recently is I've been spending
with time on nights on some other things
okay and I want to know how you feel
about diversifying streams of income for
me I mean other people are like you
should be putting 110% that one thing
which I am but I think I think that your
entrepreneurial and your curious and
even if what you're doing at night
completely fails you needed to scratch
that itch and it's a hundred percent ROI
positive thing is it's growing crazy
right now
go figure there's only so many hours in
the day I could sleep for every night at
some point listen I think it comes down
to are you willing to [ __ ] your brothers
see ya
[Applause]
[Music]
I sure can thanks man I appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
hammer 16 woods you go back on tires
you know to be very frank I would tell
myself that I was right you know at 16 I
had a very strong vision even though it
wasn't obvious that I was an
entrepreneur as a business man and that
you know even though college and my
guidance counselor were telling me I was
a loser and this and that I was focused
and I was willing to give up a lot to
get to where I wanted and I'm glad I did
yeah all right so simple as that
everybody's like this morning
just [ __ ] do it like I want it like
this is not a joke I want to know where
you bought that okay like I want to know
where you bought that champion yeah like
that's interesting to me
I got everything's interesting all right
we're all interesting to each other
we're not interesting to ourselves
I'll be honest I believe the volume
for months thank you but it's been it's
been a great four months it's been like
I read all your books we're gonna buy
new shoes and thank you
I hear pickle guy I am these are
actually from here in Hamilton family
owned and operated pickles party I love
pickles I love thank you very much and
root beer and pop shop I love that one
for iris and you wouldn't I love Tyler
Tyler takes them take some root beer
thank you brother you're never going to
believe this this is a blog this is real
[ __ ] literally literally yesterday in
the office I wish I said something I
walked by a Boehner truck 73 that I have
in my office and I said to myself with
the whole five thing I'm like it's just
gonna be a moment like any moment
somebody's gonna make me a Vaynerchuk
five [ __ ] fresh man I [ __ ] love it
my personal life has been really good
like my work like really good like I'm a
filmmaker
and then like a bunch of stuff happening
like in my Fresno line
been really unmotivated today it's only
been two weeks
like is it really bad somebody died
you just need a couple of weeks let me
tell you something you're so young you
can't judge your life based on two weeks
you could be in a slum for three months
but then in four months you're back
don't judge yourself for not being
productive while you're being emotional
put it into perspective it's [ __ ] two
weeks three months out of your entire
life it doesn't mean [ __ ] you're gonna
get a better girlfriend you're gonna
like it better very first book from you
the classic yes
Pyrus you were like 13 when this [ __ ]
came out or someone who grew up with a
hard childhood how do they overcome that
by yelling out loud the poison that was
okay the way you own it yeah it's by
putting it out there
it's only new because of its secrets
you understand once we put it out it's
over
look this entire evening is why I'm
emotional you guys so many of you are
keeping a secret inside that's just
insecurities that your mom gave you or
your dad gave you or your older sibling
gave you a lot of you were sitting with
them half of you are sitting with them I
met you tonight the fact that I know
that if you meet a video right now and
just told your truth if you did if you
did if you did if you just took [ __ ]
Instagram right now flipped it and set
it it would change your [ __ ] life
your poison is your secret can't imagine
what your secret's doing to you you want
to do it you want a little airport
carry-on
I mean it's only half there for carriers
but I already got the beanie but I could
switch to a different beanie
I'm gonna give it to you
here we go 1 1
DICE [ __ ] intensity Toronto I [ __ ]
love your city so [ __ ] much I just
love this [ __ ] city and I just want
everybody know when you put now good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] comes back shits so basic
please allow me to be the permission for
you to try to live your life the way you
want to please please allow me that
amazing gift if you don't do it for me
do it for Airport Gary see ya
[Music]